bonjour et mitel merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation sur rt france alors
votre réaction suite à l'adoption en
deuxième lecture du projet de loi
bioéthique mais je lisais sur votre
antenne le tweet du président la
république
j'ai l'impression qu'on n'a pas assisté
tout à fait au même débat d'une part
parce qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un texte
équilibré
je crois que jamais dans l'histoire
parlementaire récente un texte de loi
n'avait tenté d'introduire de telles
modifications civilisationnel
anthropologique de la veille même
d'ailleurs des députés la république en
marche
je pense évidemment à la pma son père
mais on pourrait aussi citer la création
d'embryons chimères mi homme mi animal
l'arpa qui est une gpa qui ne dit pas
son nom ou l'extension du diane du
diagnostic préimplantatoire qui est un
humanisme à peine voilée et tout ça au
milieu de l'été dans un mépris quand
même des parlementaires de l'opposition
puisque le des ministres ont été très
très peu présents et ils ont lorsqu'ils
étaient présents assez assez rarement un
daigné répondre aux questions des
parlementaires
donc on a quand même le sentiment d'un
débat confisqué aux français et d'un
texte qui est tout sauf eux sauf
équilibré on a l'impression que ça a été
fait en catimini un certain l'opposition
ont fustigé le fait que ce vote se
déroule à la dernière semaine de la
session parlementaire c'est un sujet
qu'il aurait fallu débattre à un autre
moment pour vous oui je pense que c'est
un sujet majeur il est question au
travers de ce texte le tenir de
l'humanité on acte peut-être d'un
changement et civilisationnel on parle
d'un renversement d'un bouleversement
éthiques
je crois que sur ces questions les
français auraient dû pouvoir prendre
part au débat et je crois qu'à
république en marche a organisé en fait
d'un différence autour de ce texte en
passant milieu l'été en organisant aussi
l'absence du gouvernement lors de la
commission spéciale qui avaient préparé
la lecture de ce texte
ce qui de fait a éloigné un peu
l'attention des uns et des autres sur ce
qui était en train de se jouer
il ya eu tout de même quelques abandons
de la pma postmoderne de l'arpa vous en
avez parlé tout à l'heure le don
d'ovocytes au sein d'un couple de femmes
en vue d'une pma est ce que c'est une
bonne chose
oui effectivement il ya eu quelques
quelques abandons salutaire que vous
venez de mentionner et je pense qu'à ce
titre il faut il faut saluer
l'engagement d'un certain nombre de
parlementaires qui jour et nuit jusqu'à
encore 3h30 du matin
aujourd'hui se sont battus avec des
débats d'une qualité quand même assez
assez rare pour protéger les valeurs
humaines auxquelles on est tous attachés
et donc je me félicite effectivement de
ces abandons
merci beaucoup a dit elle rappelle que
vous êtes fondateur de marianne conseil
est un chroniqueur